[Music]
whenever they got maybe
[Music]
landing grounds
and in the street
never surrender
[Music]
I'm Victor Davis Hanson I'm a senior
fellow in classics and military history
at Stanford University's Hoover
Institution and I'm a teaching fellow a
visiting professor at Hillsdale College
this is my 15th year that I've had the
pleasure of teaching at Hillsdale and
I'm also the author of the recent second
world wars today I'd like to talk about
the role of air power in the course of
World War two World War two of course is
the word we use in America and it's
equivalent to the European or the
British notion of a second world war
there's a couple of things to remember
about air power before we begin in
earnest one is that there was an
enormous transformation between its
inaugural appearance in 1914 in World
War one when pilots and biplanes shot
revolvers at each other in less than 30
years about 25 years 24 years at the
outbreak in September first of 1939 in
World War two we had mono planes and the
speeds had increased from a hundred
miles an hour to nearly 300 and people
were firing about seven to eight hundred
shots per minute on machine guns
sometimes right through the propeller
sometimes on the wings and they were
carrying bomb loads in the case of
fighter bombers of five hundred to a
thousand pounds and bombers even far
greater so there was a miraculous
transformation in the role of air power
and that created theorists or prophets
Air prophets or architects of air power
so to speak in the European countries
and in the United States as well Billy
Mitchell duet Weaver in Germany and they
were so enthralled by this new weapon
that they made it a series of astounding
predictions and so much that Prime
Minister Stanley Baldwin in the late
1930s had in despair that the bomber
will always get through and it was
almost as if assets at sea navies and
assets on the ground infantry were going
to be secondary or even irrelevant the
or would it take place up in the air the
problem with that is nobody lives up in
the air nobody eats in the air nobody
really can fly we don't have wings so
what you're doing is transferring label
labor and capital from the ground up
into the air and there has to be a
purpose for that and the purpose had to
be either air superiority or air
supremacy and by that I mean your air
forces had to beat the other person's
air forces for the prime reason that
they could then direct their assets to
where things really mattered on the
ground taking cities or territory or
killing people or capturing them on the
ground if you couldn't do that and you
only achieved air parity then both sides
were sort of wasting their time and in
our elevant theater so the purpose was
to build more planes and better planes
and train better pilots to destroy the
enemy's air assets or at least weaken
them so you had air superiority and then
the holy grail was air supremacy that
meant that you could put your assets up
in the air they could fly over the
enemy's territory destroy his cities or
his armies on the ground and they would
be invulnerable because you had
destroyed the enemy's ability to fight
back in the air and that was pretty much
the theory of airpower in World War two
there's a couple of other very important
concepts to remember about world war two
in general that apply in particular to
air power the war was known as a series
of Wars from September 1939 to the
invasion of the Soviet Union in June of
1941 and by that I mean they still
referred they being the general public
the World War one is the Great War it
was only after the invasion of the
Soviet Union and six months later the
subsequent declaration of war on the
United States by Germany and Italy as
well as four days earlier the surprise
attack at Pearl Harbor that it was
conceived as a global war that had
replaced World War one and
became world war two it's a very
important concept you see because there
was a method to the access victories
before 1941 Germany invades Poland
Denmark Norway Luxembourg Holland
Belgium Belgium France and yuccas la vie
and in those nine victories there were
commonalities they were all surprise
attacks they were all conducted against
neighbors and they were all waged by
Germany and to a lesser extent later
Italy against neighbors who were not
fully prepared in other words they had
felt that the war to end all wars had
ended in 1918 would ensure perpetual
peace in the case of the British they
were and the French they thought
appeasement are the idea of giving in to
Hitler or Mussolini would temper their
territorial ambitions in the case of the
United States they felt to be
isolationist was much wiser not to get
entangled in Europe's problems in the
case of the Soviet Union it was active
collusion under the non-aggression pact
of August 1939 that meant that they
would supply material to the Axis powers
Germany especially and then in exchange
they wouldn't have a war with the Soviet
Union but they would direct their
attention to destroying capitalist
democracies in Europe but the final
result of all this was people made wrong
impressions they said my gosh Germany
just wins blitzkrieg this combined use
of Tanks and rapid motorized transport
and Junkers 87 dive bombing attacks and
joiners 17 level bombing this is amazing
you can't stop this juggernaut
[Music]
and it's Dumas ooh
[Music]
on September 1st phanzig is incorporated
into the right and all Europe is a plane
World War two is a reality but nobody
ever stopped and took a deep breath and
said has Germany's air power along with
its ground forces has it ever really
encountered an enemy that it didn't
surprise attack that was ready for it is
it able to go in vast distances not just
across the border into Poland or into
France but 1,500 miles to the Volga
River can it reach the United States can
it reach even Britain that's an island
and the answers were increasingly
apparent that for all of the air for a
minute formidable air assets of Germany
it could not do that the second general
theme of airpower in world war ii was
the Allies and by the Allies I'm mostly
talking about the alliance that emerged
after 1941 and that was the Soviet Union
Great Britain and the United States that
group of allies emphasized practicality
and numbers in other in other words if
they build a tank or an airplane the
overriding rationale was is it durable
is it easily maintained is it easily
operated is it cheap to produce in
opposition to that Germany and Japan had
a very different concept we have to
build the biggest ship or we can will
conceive of the biggest bomber or we
have to have the closest calibrations on
our cylinder head and piston or we have
to have the finest craftsmanship and the
net result was that in theory a German
fighter our Japanese fighter might have
superior maneuverability our rate of
ascent in 1939 40 40 and 41 but it did
not have the numbers or the pilot
training or the support network to
ensure there would be more planes in the
air than the enemy and so what happened
is Germany declared war in 39 with a
wonderful error on the loop
and it had been seriously training and
in production and organized from about
1937 even though had been outlawed by
the Versailles Treaty but its enemies in
Europe had not been doing much at all so
it found it very easy to achieve not
just air superiority but air supremacy
by 1939 it went into Poland it was
bombing Warsaw within four or five days
without serious opposition in the air
when it went into Denmark it it over ran
the country in four days Norway was a
little bit more difficult because for
the first time it encountered elements
of the Royal Air Force of Great Britain
but nevertheless it was much closer and
it had more assets and it defeated the
British in Norway in the case of France
case of Yugoslavia the Low Countries
Greece again it was fighting a neighbor
that was proximate and was surprised and
had not fully armed to the extent that
Germany had by 1939 and 1940 and this
created an aura of invincibility no-one
asked in Great Britain or the Soviet
Union or the United States simple
questions for example is the mr. Schmidt
bf-109 the superb German fighter that
had done so well in Poland the Low
Countries and the european conflicts
around germany was it actually superior
to any other fighter that Great Britain
could put in the air
specifically the Spitfire fire
Supermarine Spitfire was it better than
anything the United States had for
example in terms of fighters was it
better than the p40 perhaps was it
better than the wildcat fighter perhaps
but was it better than things that were
going to emerge very quickly like the
p38 Lockheed and soon the p-47 and
people were even dreaming of a p-51 and
the answer was not clear and more
importantly people did not ask a second
question when you fight an existential
war the question must be do you have the
ability to destroy the enemy's means of
production now obviously when
he went into Poland and they went into
France oh they went into Yugoslavia in
Greece they had enough air superiority
that they could destroy these regional
air forces and then bomb strategic
targets and then enforce terms on the
defeated but that was a very different
question than saying to the Russians we
have air superiority to such a degree
that we can go all the way to Moscow or
Stalingrad or Leningrad and destroy your
cities that's a very different
proposition you have to have forward
based fields you have to have a superb
train mechanics that will go with your
airplanes far away from Germany's
borders and you also must have reliable
fuel supplies can you attack the United
States can you send a bomber 3,000 miles
and hit New York can you even bomb
London systematically to such a degree
that you'll destroy its means of
production and the answer of that was
pretty clear by 1914 39 and 40 of the
answer was no and why was the answer of
no if you look at the strategic
decisions that were made at in air power
the most alarming for Germany was they
never built an a bomber with four
engines now of course they had superb
two engine bombers the Junkers and
earners and Ankle models were all very
good airplanes but a medium bomber with
two engines cannot carry more than four
or five thousand pounds of explosive a
four-engine bomber you can double that
load and you can double the range why
didn't terminate do that and part of the
reason was it was so successful that it
visioned war as one of conquering
neighbors in the general vicinity of
Europe and then of course other powers
would be so impressed or awed they'd say
we can't defeat Germany let's come to
terms with it so the United States our
Great Britain and the Soviet Union would
make a deal rather than face the
onslaught of the Luftwaffe
[Music]
[Music]
there was another couple of reasons the
Germans got in their mind early in the
1930s that dive-bombing taking bombers
and diving down on the ground rather
than going higher in the air insured
great greater accuracy that was a flawed
concept as you can see because the idea
of brick taking a four engine or two
engine bomber down to the ground and
putting it within range of flak
batteries was sort of crazy and then the
third flawed concept was Germany felt
that you could put two engines behind
each other and on one drive shaft so you
would only have to what they called nut
cells two engines that were exposed and
that would have less drag but they would
be so powerful they would sort of have
the speed and the efficiency of a
four-engine bomber all of those concepts
turned out to be flawed and Germany went
in the war in 1939 without a bomber that
could really deliver a sustainable load
to Great Britain at least enough
firepower to destroy its means of
production it could not reach the United
States and it could not reach the Soviet
Union and the same was true of Italy and
the same was true of Japan Italy in the
case of directing its efforts in the
Balkans Japan fighting since 1931 on and
off in Manchuria and then later China
and then later in Southeast Asia again
the same formula applies easy victories
due to surprise attack superior
preparation in the 1930s and proximity
none of those factors applied to
fighting a whole array of new new
challenges after 1941 and that was the
great distances of the Soviet Union
crossing the ocean to hit the United
States and defeating superior British
airpower and naval power to conquer the
item to Great Britain so somewhere
around 1941 to 1942 the Axis powers
recalibrated and they said my gosh we're
now on a war with the United States
since December 11th 1941 we are
or with Soviet Union since June 21st of
1941 and we never conquered Great
Britain and we have not been able to
bomb the enemy into submission or even
in some cases even reach the enemy so
then what happened well what happened
would be then that there were two races
so to speak concurrent races in Japan
and Italy and Germany they recalibrated
their strategic and industrial policy
can we make a fighter that is so much
better than anything that the Allies
have can we have a new weapon can we
have a new bomber that can somehow
rectify our tragic mistake of taking on
economic industrial and military powers
beyond our comprehension in 1941 there
was a active discussion both in Germany
and in Japan that something had gone
wrong these border wars that had been so
successful in China Southeast Asia
Europe had now blossomed into something
they hadn't quite conceived of and the
answer as we're going to see is going to
be no they did not build a four-engine
bomber they did not build fighters that
were capable of ensuring air supremacy
and they did not train pilots or
maintenance crews that could ensure air
supremacy meanwhile in the United States
and Great Britain and the Soviet Union
there were quantum leaps in technology
and industrial production and remember
one other thing is that the United
States was 3,000 miles distant from
Europe Great Britain was always an
island so even though through
isolationism and appeasement the
democracies were not really ready for
World War two there were people within
them that understood would there ever be
another war you would have to have a
means of hitting a European city that
was hostile with bombs from your own
home bases whether it was the United
States or whether it would be in Britain
and that created a need for a
four-engine bomber so as early as 1936
and since 37 the United States had
developed this wonderful b-17
and Britain had experimented with a
Handley page or the Sterling short
bombers again four-engine bombers were
build as early as 1937 to 39 in the
democracies and the axis had no
counterpart to that and that gave them a
head start because from the b-17 you
would get the b-24 and then later the
b-29 and from the Sterling short or the
Handley page it would go to the
Manchester than the Lancaster
so by 1944 and 45 when we talk about
strategic bombing we're essentially
talking about an allied phenomenon the
Axis powers did not have the equipment
the technology that training or the
expertise and they simply ceased even
trying to do it as far as fighters go
the same concept holds true that the
United States and Britain as being
Island and distant powers and some
extent the Soviet Union started to put a
premium on distance and concepts like
drop usable reusable or drop tanks so
that a fighter could have its regular
gasoline tank but also could have one
that would drop when it got a sufficient
distance and entered combat so the
ranges for Allied aircraft started to
exceed 150 200 300 400 500 miles that
were allow them to escort bombers all
the way into Europe and so when we look
at the individual fighters on the two
sides of the conflict by 1941 everything
is starting to flip to reverse the
wonderful mr. Schmitt 109 and the new
focke-wulf 190 are now being matched in
the United States by p-47 p38 and
especially a p-51 fighter that was
superior in every category in Britain
the Supermarine Spitfire will go through
iterations from model 1 to 9 and very
quickly it will match the 109 and the
190 and even become far more versatile
90% of the aviation fuel
in World War two was produced or refined
either under British or American
auspices so you had more fuel if you
have more fuel you have more time to
train crews there will be a ten-to-one
advantage in personnel in the Army Air
Forces in Britain the United States and
the Soviet Union in other words they
will have more fuel and they'll have
more money and more time to train crews
not with ten or twenty hours but fifty a
hundred three hundred hours of training
before they enter combat this will all
come to fruition about 1943 and 1944 in
which the Allies will essentially
destroy the Luftwaffe and destroy the
Japanese naval and army air forces at
the same time this is happening the
Americans are starting to believe that
they can send these unique four-engine
bombers and britain britain can't and go
into the continent of europe and they're
thereby avoid a land war why would they
want to avoid a land war because they're
haunted in the case of Britain by the
Verdun battle or the Somme battles of
World War one Horrible's casualties 1
million British dead million I have
French dead and they don't want to
repeat that and the architects of air
power said you know what a four-engine
bomber can go to Germany or occupied
France or Eastern Europe and do what in
land army could do without the
commiserate casualties Japan to a
certain extent had the same idea that it
had not built a four-engine bomber it
only had fighters and the United States
then would only reach Japan through air
power it would have to have bases close
enough but it would bomb Japan into
submission and so from 43 to 45 there
was a real question that the Allies
alone had four-engine bombers and
strategic air forces and they were going
to try to hit Cologne Berlin Bremen
occupied German cities as well as
Yokohama or Tokyo and could they do it
such a way that in terms of cost-benefit
analysis they would inflict more damage
more quickly than they would suffer
losses themselves by 1943 it looked for
a while that the axis had the advantages
and by that I mean there were not enough
quality fighters to escort a b-17 or a
b24 into the Romanian oil fields or the
ball bearing factories at Schweinfurt
our to bomb Japan from India and China
there were great distances the engines
were not able to take huge loads of
bombs that high up to avoid flak
batteries and there were not enough
fighters that had arranged to accompany
the Allied fire bombing fleets and so if
we looked at Allied bombing in 1943 we
would say my gosh
we're losing 8 and 10% per mission we
haven't stopped the German industrial
juggernaut we can't reach Tokyo from
China or India and the architects of air
power were wrong we're bombing a lot of
things but either the bombs are not
hitting targets or we're losing so many
planes in the process 9 10 11 men per
loss plane that this is not a
sustainable proposition so one of two
things had to happen either the Allies
had to come up with new tactics or new
machines or they were going to lose the
air war and then it was going to look
like something like World War 1 and
where if they were able to invade there
would be trench warfare and it would be
a terrible slog analogous to Verdun the
salm and so what happened was that
sometime in 1943 the aggregate aggregate
experience of early bombing of Germany
and occupied Europe started to pay
dividends and by that I mean they
started to recalibrate the b-17 with
more armament better radar better crew
training the new b-24 had a little bit
more range a little bit more bomb
capacity they started to improve their
land-based radar that could predict
patterns and fighter defense and
most importantly they developed a p-47
and a p-51 fighter with drop tanks that
were able to start escorting American
and British bombers all the way to
Germany and finally they invaded France
in June of 1944 and suddenly instead of
going over a hostile British channel and
a hostile France and then into Germany
and occupied Europe they found that they
could put fighter bases in occupied
France that was now under their control
and so they would have a pretty safe and
secure route of passage at least until
the German border and when you add all
of these refinements strange things
started to happen by about 1944 in other
words British and American bombers
started to go from 8 7% losses per
mission down to one or two general Jimmy
Doolittle the architect of the 8th Air
Force's Fighter Wing began to refine new
tactics and say if you're a p-47 or p-51
or a Spitfire fighter pilot you're now
free to go after fighters without
clinging or being in the general
vicinity or protecting the b-17 of the
Lancaster bomber and so almost as if
they were wolf pack's
American and British fighters roamed all
over the ground they attacked airfields
they waited for German fighters to land
or take off and they began to literally
destroy 20 percent per month of the
Luftwaffe this started to pay off by
August of 1944 where a b-17 mission or
Lancaster mission was now pretty free
just drop bombs and all of the
industrial centres of Europe it's a
great question today that we ponder was
it worth it
40,000 Americans were killed 40,000 or
so British Airmen were killed and yet up
until 1944 there were very meager
results in terms of harming fighter
production Bob
barring production food production
electricity production and yet after
nineteen of mid-1944 we started to see
enormous results in destroying
transportation aircraft production and
t'ankin tank
and vehicle production so we have this
continual debate today as air power did
work or didn't work the people say it
didn't work it was 80,000 people weren't
worth it we lost over 5,000 bomber
planes we spent 40% of our military
budget and yet German industrial
production kept going the defenders of
air power said well we had to we had to
make the necessary investments we lost
men and materiel learning how to fly in
the proper formation how to have the
proper fighter the proper fighter
tactics a proper radar but once we
learned that we destroyed Germany's
industrial production and it's not quite
accurate to say it continued to increase
in terms of vehicle or aircraft
production because Germany really wasn't
mobilized until Albert Speer the Czar of
German industry took control of the
economy in late 1943 once he did that we
were destroying the increase in
production and Speirs planned economy
was not sustainable so even though it
increased it did not increase at the
rate that it would otherwise have had we
not been bombing around the clock now by
the end of 1944 air power in world war
ii was definitely a British and American
until lesser extent Soviet monopolies so
something had to change if the war was
going to be salvaged on the part of the
Axis powers and what we'll see in the
end of 1944 in the first months of 1945
is a desperate axis attempt to somehow
reach ange the relative strengths now
they can't do it but in terms of
production about 50 miles from where I'm
speaking right now at Willow Run
the United States is building a b-24
Liberator bomber at the rate of one per
hour and we're going to build over
20,000 of four-engine bombers late-model
for injured bombers here in the United
States of the 800,000 or so air frames
which would be fighters bombers and
trainers about 600,000 were built in the
United States and about another hundred
thousand were built in the British
Empire so about 90 85 to 90 depending on
how we defined a warplane we're gonna be
built on the Allied side how then is
Germany and to a lesser extent Italy in
Japan going to redress that imbalance
and stop the bombing in the case of
Germany and Italy of their homeland and
the case of Japan of stopping and ekat
bombing attack in 1944 and the answer
they came up with was characteristic of
axis thinking it was going to be
superior technology it wasn't going to
be more manpower more training more
practical weapons greater industrial
production remember at this time the
United States factories in Detroit or
Oakland or the Midwest or the south are
completely immune from attack there has
not been a serious attack in Great
Britain in three years
Soviet Union has moved most of its
industrial capacity on the other side of
the Ural Mountains so you have an
asymmetrical situation in which the
Allies are building more and better
weapons with impunity and the axis power
or in the case of Italy in Germany in
late 1943 in the case of Italy before
1943 are constantly under assault so
where did they come up with well
Hitler came up with what you would
expect a bold almost brilliant we could
say but completely unrealistic and
impractical solution and it was
characterized by what we would call
cruise missiles a v1 rocket system and
then later a v2
listing missile would be the forerunner
of an arrant continental ballistic
missile the v2 program and then the 262
mr. Schmitt jet and the idea was well we
don't have as much industry and we don't
have as many people as the Allies but
one axis pilot in a jet with rockets can
destroy an entire b-17 formation or a v1
or a v2 rocket can hit London and create
create such terror or hit a big factory
without the loss of a pilot that they
will seek terms the problem with all of
these solutions were that they did not
have a plan that in the way of the
Allies to ask themselves how much does
it cost to deliver a pound of explosive
to Britain by a v1 rocket or a v2 rocket
or a four-engine bomber and the answer
if they had to ask that question the
answer they would have come up with was
it's pretty cheap to send 2,000 pounds
of explosive at 180 miles an hour on a
v1 rocket or 250 depending on the
payload but it's not very economical
descended a ballistic missile with 2,000
or 3,000 power in fact it costs 20 times
more to put a bomb on a v2 rocket than
it did on a v1 cruise missile and yet
they built at least ten thousand six
hundred six thousand of which were
delivered at London and they almost did
no damage it killed about four thousand
tragically they killed about four
thousand British civilians the v2
rockets did but they did no industrial
damage the v1 killed even more British
citizens but again they were a weapon of
terror they could not be directed
accurately at a British factory they
enraged the British public they diverted
British bombers strength to find v1 and
v2 fields in occupied Belgium and France
and later in Holland but they did not do
damage as
vision to the British Empire and they
could not reach the United States and
they could not reach the Soviet Union
and yet the money the research and
development costs that went into these
terror weapons of the v1 cruise missile
and the v2 rocket were comparable to the
American Manhattan Project that produced
the bombs that were dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki in the case of the 262 mr.
Schmitt jet it achieved fantastic speeds
of 475 nearly 500 miles an hour which
was about 50 to 75 miles an hour faster
than any prop driven plane whether it
was the Mosquito fighter bomber on the
British side or the p-51 American that
had a superb British Merlin rolls-royce
engine in it so in theory they were
invulnerable you could take it to 60 to
take off and nobody could catch it it
could dive into a b-17 but the problem
the formation and wreak havoc but the
problem was again they didn't produce
very many we were producing ten twelve
fifteen thousand p-51s p-47s p38
Corsairs Hellcats in the Pacific whereas
the Germans were only producing about
1,200 jets they were very hard to fly
they required a special fuel mixtures
and they were very vulnerable at takeoff
and so the jet program really after some
initial novel successes almost was
without really major results in Japan it
was quite different because the Japanese
until late 1944 had not been bombed
remember the Japanese strategy had been
concentric rings we're going to have the
greater a Asia co-prosperity sphere
around Japan so we have islands like
Okinawa or Iwo Jima and the first ring
and then we go out to Wake Island we go
into Tarawa New Guinea Java we get to
the Philippines Singapore Southeast Asia
and China and what that meant was it was
very hard for an
can aircraft to find anywhere whether it
was on a carrier a fighter bomber or
whether it was a strategic b-17 or B 20
for later b-29 anywhere where they could
hit Japan so the American idea was Japan
is not going to be defeated until we can
destroy its industry or we can invade
the homeland and cut out the heart of
this monster but how can we do it when
he can't get close enough so a
third-generation bomber was envisioned
and this project was that the b-29
project was also a billion dollar plus
research and development project as
expensive as the Manhattan Project and
the idea was we're going to build a
four-engine bomber that can go up 30,000
feet and it can fly 1,600 miles one way
and we will base them in India or we
base them in China we will stop worrying
about fighter escort or flak because
they could not hit us at 30,000 feet and
unfortunately for the Americans it was a
disaster in November December of 1944 in
January in February in 1945 simply
because by the time you load a b-29 with
ten or fifteen thousand pounds of
explosives and take it up to 30,000 feet
and fly it 1,600 miles over the jet
stream of Japan and you have to import
oil by air and gas and lubricants to
service a b-29 all the way to India
China it's it's too expensive and the
results don't justify the cost so the
Americans were in a dilemma as late as
nineteen for February of 1945 Japan was
untouched and yet people were talking
about we got to invade the Japanese
homeland
so the solution they came up with is
let's use the b-29 from an island that
weak will take within 1,600 miles so in
late 1944 we invaded the Mariana Islands
Guam Tinian and Saipan we made seven
thousand foot Coral runways and by
February we were launching two to three
hundred b-29s and they would fly 1,600
mile
one way so you can imagine the toll on
the cruise even though it was a
fantastic plane it had a pressurized
cabin but it still was very hard to go
up to 30,000 feet and drop bombs it
would blow off course and we were not
getting any results we were losing a
number of cruised to plane pilot air
missing the target getting lost on the
way at night all the way to Japan and
the new plane itself the engines heated
up and there were 25,000 different parts
and the cockpit alone so it was it was a
new experimental plane that had not been
sufficiently tested or tried and then
something happened in late February a
new commander general Curtis LeMay took
over the b-29 program he said
essentially the cost of a b-29 is like a
destroyer it's not working the public is
bewildered the military is angry we're
gonna do something different we're going
to fly to Japan and take advantage of
the jet stream rather than let the jet
stream take advantage of us we're gonna
take this beautiful bomber this highly
technologically sophisticated bomber and
drop it down to 7,000 feet people were
aghast they said you know a Radian or
zero fighter can't hit us at 30,000 feet
LeMay answered back I'm not gonna wear
out the engines trying to get up that
high with that much explosive in fact
we're not even to use explosive rather
than have a bomb blow off course at a
400 mile an hour jet stream we're going
to come in on the jet stream very low
and we're gonna use a new substance
called napalm which was a magnesium
aluminum liquefied gasoline weapon and
we're gonna drop these bombs on mostly a
wooden infrastructure of the Japanese
urban cores and we're gonna let the wind
do the work and people said well why did
we build a b-29 it was supposed to be a
sophisticated high-level bomber and
LeMay said don't worry we're gonna come
in so fast and we're gonna come in at
night they're not even gonna know what's
gonna hit them and on March 9th
and tenth of 1945 LeMay sent over 300
b-29s at a level of about five to seven
thousand feet they went into Tokyo and
it was the most lethal day in the
history of military conflict since
recorded history
[Music]
about a hundred to a hundred and fifty
thousand Japanese civilians soldiers
industrial workers were killed in a
raging inferno that destroyed about 14
square miles of the Japanese urban core
and from the Mariana Islands they were
not they did not pose the difficulty
that India or China did they could be
supplied by sea the enormous amounts of
gasoline could be brought in by US
tankers they were distant enough from
Japan that Japanese fighters could not
reach them and by February March of 1945
there were bases on Iwo Jima u.s.
fighter bases that could help the b-29s
as they went in Japan about half way and
could serve as emergency airfields and
the result of that was from 1945 during
1945 from February until June the US
Army Air Force essentially burned down
80% of the industrial production of
Japan at the same time this was
happening there had been an earlier
project to develop a nuclear weapon and
that was manifested over Hiroshima with
a uranium bomb of about 15 kilotons and
over Nagasaki with a much more efficient
plutonium bomb of about 19 Killah cons
and that meant that the United States
now had two different prongs a very
successful conventional fire rating
strategy but a new weapon that was so
awesome that it might shock the Japanese
into surrender and remember the purpose
of these bombing campaigns along with
submarine campaigns that attack Japanese
tanker fleets supplying strategic
materials to the homeland and mining the
harbors so that even if they got through
a submarine Wolfpack they could not dock
because the harbors were mine was to
stop the invasion of Japan we had gone
in to Okinawa on April 1st and by June
mid-june
early July of 1945 we had secured
Okinawa but we had lost 50,000
casualties and the Japanese had created
a new weapon a kamikaze suicide bomber
and it was essentially a cruise missile
the human brain substituting for a
sophisticated computer and they found
that if you took a obsolete zero fighter
and you put a pilot in it that was going
on a one-way mission and he was
navigating the plane in a way much more
sophisticated than a v1 or v2 rocket
even and he could double the range
because he didn't have to come back he
only had to go one way on his fuel
supply and he was either going a few
feet above the ocean and was therefore
impervious to radar detection or was
going very high so when he came out of
the clouds he could reach speeds of
nearly 400 miles it was a devastating
cruise weapon and off Okinawa they lost
about 17 major ships and we had over 300
attacks on other ships and the result
was we lost about 12,000 dead Marines
and sailors on the island and off the
island and 50,000 total casualties and
people the United States went into panic
if you take the assets on Okinawa and
you multiply them by 20 or 30 which we
knew existed on the Japanese mainland
over five million potential soldiers
7,000 kamikaze pilots how are we going
to take this island are we gonna have to
give up like World War one and sort of
say let's have an armed assist and lead
their government intact and so the
answer was we have to find a weapon that
precludes losing a million casualties
through a land invasion and that's what
was the impetus behind the use of the
atomic bombs I will say at the same time
that this was happening LeMay was
although he knew that there was the 509
composite b-29 atomic squadron he was
very confused about the entire program
he said wait wait a minute
I have burned down 85% of the urban core
of Japan
you're not gonna have to invade we can
stop the Russians from getting into
Japan or taking over all of Korea and
they had come in and mid-august if
you'll just let me continue my
incendiary campaign and by that II meant
we now have Okinawa may have been unwise
to take it it may have been too costly
but we have it it's not sixteen hundred
miles from Japan like Saipan or Tinian
or Guam it's only three hundred and
fifty and World War two is over within
Europe and what does that mean that
means that we've got about ten thousand
bombers b-17s b-24s British Lancaster's
medium b-25s and six we can bring them
all over to Okinawa and we have another
two thousand b-29s on order and we still
have the 2,500 b-29s with these superior
bomb loads in the Marianas and between
the mariana b-29s and the new okinawa
fields we can fly not three times a week
or four times we can fly twice a day and
we can have ten or fifteen thousand
bombers and he was envisioning and
thence inferno that's almost comparable
to something out of Dante's Inferno and
we don't know what would have been the
effect of that fire ray but it would
have largely precluded a land invasion
of Japan so if we you sort of aggregate
all of these considerations into a final
analysis I think we can say that the
dropping of the two bombs at Hiroshima
and Nagasaki precluded a fire campaign
that would have killed far more Japanese
than would have been lost an American
invasion and probably would have
precluded the need for an American army
to land on the Japanese islands so we
usually say well the b-29 b-29s that
dropped the two atomic bombs were only
necessary to stop a land invasion or
they were used by Truman to show Stalin
be careful we have the ability to
deliver a nuclear weapon or they were
just terror weapons or they were
manifestations of American racism no I
don't think any of that there
they're not logical assumptions I think
the real reason that we drop these two
atomic bombs were do we really want to
starve the Japanese people or to burn
most of this the civilian population a
liar because we have the capability now
with using the assets from two theaters
and the Okinawa Okinawa bases to Nate
napalm Japan back into the Stone Age as
we conclude the the idea of airpower in
World War two we have to ask ourselves
what was it all about was it worth it
40% of the US budget was invested in
bombers and fighters and transport
planes is somewhat similar in the case
of Britain and the answer I think is yes
because the way to look at it is Britain
fought the first day of the war
September 1st all the way to September
2nd 1945 and with a surrender of Japan
it was the only country that come in the
first day of the war and lasts to the
very last day in the United States from
December 8 1941 to September 2nd 1945
but if you look at it that way
the United States lost about 400,000
dead through accidents disease and
combat Britain lost a little bit fewer
and yet defeated a far more formidable
enemy than was true in World War one in
other words Germany Japan and Italy were
far more powerful allies and enemies
than had been cut the Imperial German
army of World War one and how did they
do that and how do they lose only about
two to three percent of their entire
military forces and the answer was C
power and air power did one thing they
avoided the need to land in Europe at
the very beginning of 1940-41 in the
case of British and in the United States
and 42 or 43 in Japan in other words we
did not do what we did in nineteen
17 the case of America and the British
in 1914 we did not bleed white our
ground forces to take the enemy capital
and knock the enemy out of the war we
bombed them into submission and
therefore precluded a and invasion of
Japan entirely and we precluded an
invasion of Europe until we were ready
to do it in June 1944 so the ultimate
verdict I think on airpower was it was
very costly it did not work too well and
41 42 and 43 but the Allies gained the
lessons and achieved air superiority and
eventually air supremacy that by 1944
1945 is saved thousands of lives it was
one of the greatest successes of World
War two in our next episode we're going
to see that the twin of air power was
naval power and fortunately for the
Allies they began the war with the
world's largest the British Navy and the
world's second largest Navy the American
Navy and by the end of the war the
American Navy would have more ships and
naval tonnage than all the navies in a
World War two put together and as a twin
to air power we'll explain why they
always won
[Music]